this is back to my dating life I think
one of the essential fundamental
research questions I'm wondering about
is uh the Dynamics and
um
so the details of how you have sex in
space
um asking for a friend of course I mean
that's there literally is sort of work
on this right because like if you think
about long-term space travel
I mean
sex is uh
so like the there's the recreational
aspects of sex but the most important
aspect of sex for long-term space travel
is um
uh procreations
and also the full biological cycle of
that so that from the embryo of the
development of the baby the giving the
birth and all that kind of stuff so like
you know there's a lot of really
difficult
problems of biology there to understand
and uh but perhaps it's all some of that
again just like you said brilliantly
some of that can be just solved with
engineering outside of the human body by
creating a gravitational field like that
but maybe along the way you can figure
out how to do that without doing it but
we're balancing the cost and so on and
radiation is the other thing we know we
have a really good data set on what
radiation and doses do to humans and we
we know we can measure radiation we know
we can approximate you know and kind of
give edge cases for the Mars transient
and getting to Mars and being on Mars
and the simple answer to that is like at
the end of the day if we have to you
know dig into Mars or find a tunnel to
to live in so you get some extra mass in
between you and Cosmic radiation so be
it like that's the that's the answer
then again none of these are like
insolvable problems they're just things
the hurdles you would have to overcome
based on
you know the the risk exposure and the
posture there imagine being
the first
child the first baby born
outside of Earth
that'd be pretty cool yeah I would love
to be alive to see that that's a big one
I don't know if they'll um
I don't know because it's such a
dangerous thing it's so risky I think
that could be in our lifetime you think
so yeah
I I would like to think in a perfect
world of our thinking futurism then
30 to 50 years I definitely think we
could have a full-time like permanent
major civilizations you know like like
um
uh like what blue origin wants to
develop where they have a a huge like
sphere you know and you're doing a lot
of uh especially heavy industry off of
Earth so you're not polluting earth like
that's makes so much sense to me
um I yeah I think I think we
we could live in a lifetime where you
know we thought the since the 50s and
60s that people are going to be living
and working in space like crazy and at
any given point we're lucky to have 12
people in space today
um
but I really think In Our Lifetime we're
finally getting to that point of
yeah that that's a reality